m
25 novembre 2015 au 21 rue du renard 4e
arrondissement de paris une image
surprenante des vitrines illumine un
boulevard parisien
le conseil départemental inaugure une
boutique une galerie ci
une pièce aménagée pour retrouver ce que
la réunion a de meilleur et certains
coins sont plus apprécié que d'autres
tout ça magnifique c'est très design un
espace merveilleux j'imagine que eu
beaucoup beaucoup de travail de la part
des employés pour remettre tout ça en
exergue parce qu'on a l'impression
d'être dans une habitude que de chez sa
charge contre le lieu magnifique très
très beau de belles couleurs une belle
ambiance des vos produits des produits
de qualité qui représente vraiment l'île
de la réunion puisqu'on a un mur de lave
on a un mur végétal on a du bois des
essences rares et vraiment c'est un vrai
plaisir et on a envie de tout acheter de
partir tout de suite à l'île de la
réunion
l'antenne on va dire du département de
la réunion existe depuis fort longtemps
puisque elle a pour objet essentiel
d'assurer un homme de mission
d'accompagnement tant sociales que liés
à la mobilité des réunionnais mais à
l'occasion du repositionnement de
l'antenne géographe et jusqu'à l'antenne
est maintenant située au 20 heures rue
du rhône au coeur de paris d'utiliser
cette antenne
pour en faire une vitrine de l'île de la
réunion de son ensemble dans son
ensemble réunit pas une représentation
du département de la réunion les membres
de l'ensemble de la réunion la réunion
manqué d'une vitrine dans la capitale
comme vous le savez la réunion est
inscrite au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco de par sa diversité
on y trouve notamment des réalisations
en bois debout ya fait une espèce
végétale à la réunion sans tout c'était
extraordinaire
la france ne serait pas le mobile la
france est vice-président d'un abraham
hassani a très bien dit les choses que
cette maison elle montre les talents
elle montre la diversité des habitants
des réunionnaises et des réunionnais et
à paris combien de réunionnais et
réunionnaises vivent en france
d'ailleurs
en région parisienne la communauté
antillaise les vachement représentés et
avoir un lieu pas comme eux alors un
conseil général et la boutique
la réunion va dire assez c'est déjà une
visibilité supplémentaire beaucoup nous
kréyol fleuret le déçu sur paris on
trouve un cha le à la réunion radio tout
même pas avoir le thème de faris ufat
lantana conseil général sur paris mais
ibm est à nous des gens nous en tant que
l'association soit besoin de 1,6 à
besoins matériels et c'est à nous pour
tout amoureux vierzon et vice versa quoi
donc c'est un travail collectif on va
dire la réunion a besoin d'un lieu comme
ça à paris en tout cas car il n'y a pas
de lieu où les la diaspora réunionnaise
peut se retrouver
on est très éparpillé je sais qu'on est
très nombreux mais on ne sait pas vous
se rencontrer et je pense que ce lieu
peut être un plat de rattachement de
deux lieux on peut par exemple pendant
les fêtes faire un petit moment on se
retrouve pour manger les letchis pour
manger des samoussas et je crois que
c'est important
l'espace en tout cas s'y prête
produits péi de qualité dans une
ambiance feutrée le meilleur de notre
île a maintenant une vitrine à paris
autre niveau au sous sol une salle
d'exposition permettra aux artistes
réunionnais de présenter leurs oeuvres
où
oui
déjà de pouvoir exposer dans la maison
réunion à paris et de montrer justement
que
il ya des jeunes réunionnais artistes en
métropole et qui font partager la
diversité
qui mélangea diversité culturelle de la
réunion avec
pour cette fin d'année douceur et
couleurs de lille aideront bien des
foyers à supporter l'hiver